budget 99 allègement de la taxe
professionnelle favorable aux
entreprises refonte de la taxe
d'habitation pour les particuliers le
début d'une réforme fiscale engagée par
le gouvernement
dopage des produits interdits ne sont
pas réservées aux professionnels dans le
monde amateur on propose aussi des
cocktails détonants et très dangereux le
cinéma ne fait pas relâche en était
sortie de l' arme fatale le numéro 4 et
retour de son héros
le bo mel gibson haute couture le défilé
du maître yves saint laurent qui fête
cette année ses 40 ans de création et
qui atteint les sommets de son art
madame monsieur bonsoir
peut-être les pilotes dans quelques
heures d'une affaire dramatique qui
avait ému la france dans les années 1985
1986 la longue suite des prises d'otages
de français au liban en plus de l'équipe
d'antenne 2 marcel carton marcel
fontaine la liste des otages français
aux mains de la jihad islamique étaient
longues
à l'époque les premiers de cette
terrible série furent jean paul
kauffmann et michel seurat ce dernier
devait mourir pendant sa captivité
aujourd'hui douze ans plus tard des
fouilles ont été entreprises sur le bord
d'une route à l'entrée de beyrouth où
pourraient être enfouis son corps dans
le lyrique
c'est ici à proximité de l'aéroport
international de beyrouth qu aurait été
enterré le corps de michel seurat ancien
otage au liban
les autorités libanaises ont donné le
feu vert pour le début des recherches
cela fait des années que la femme de ce
rap tente de récupérer le corps de son
mari michel seurat historien et
sociologue spécialiste du monde arabe
avait été enlevé le 22 mai 85 par le
jihad islamique
le groupe clandestin pro iranien avait
annoncé son décès le 10 mars 86 pour son
épouse marie sera originaire d'alep en
syrie c'est peut être la fin d'un long
calvaire qui avait aussi touché tous les
français
la liberté enfin pour marcel fontaine
jean paul kauffmann et marcel carton les
otages français au liban libéré hier
soir sont arrivés ce matin à paris moi
j'ai été enlevé le 22 mai 1985 avec un
homme qui s'appelait michel seurat gg
j'étais avec lui pendant de longs mois
et puis nous l'avons vu s'éteindre peu à
peu et j'ai une certaine manière j'ai un
peu honte aujourd'hui il a d'être là
jean paul kauffmann derniers otages
libérés avant ce fut jean louis
normandin et roger auque en novembre 87
otage au liban il lui aussi philippe
rochot georges en scène
aurel cornéa retrouvé le corps de michel
seurat ce serait pour tous les anciens
otages
une façon de tourner la page très
douloureuse de ses amis noirs le
gouvernement engagé aujourd'hui une
réforme des impôts dont certaines
mesures prendront effet dès l'année
prochaine avec dans les grandes lignes
un allègement important de la taxe
professionnelle qui pèse sur les
entreprises et donc sur l'emploi et pour
les particuliers une réforme de la taxe
d'habitation et aussi des baisses
ciblées entre autres une légère
diminution de la tva envisagée notamment
sur le gaz l'électricité et une amorce
d'augmentation de la fiscalité sur le
gazole
pascal golomer quelques bonnes nouvelles
d'abord pour les ménages le taux de la
tva sera ramené de 20,6 à 5 25%
notamment pour les abonnements edf gdf
le tri sélectif des déchets est certes
un appareillage pour les personnes
handicapées les timbres fiscaux sur les
cartes d'identité et les dames conduire
seront purement et simplement supprimée
est nécessaire prochain mes droits de
mutation c'est à dire les taxes sur les
ventes de logements seront abaissés de
20%
enfin à partir de 2000 la taxe
d'habitation sera calculée selon la
valeur locative réelle actualisée des
logements ce qui devrait aboutir à une
baisse de la facture pour les revenus
les plus modestes
bonne nouvelle aussi pour les
entreprises la taxe professionnelle sur
les salaires sera supprimé en cinq ans
mais dès l'an prochain 70% les
entreprises en bénéficieront
un cadeau appréciable notamment pour les
industries de main d'oeuvre
qui n'a qu'un but c'est dans le
gouvernement réduire le chômage cette
année j'avais prévu 300 mille créations
d'emplois y aura plus que trois cent
mille créations d'emplois parce que
l'économie va plutôt un peu mieux même
que nous l'espérions
il faut continuer ça l'année prochaine
et donc l'emploi la justice fiscale
la baisse d'impôt pour la tva le tout
dans finalement une diminution des
impôts pour l'ensemble des français
quelques mauvaise nouvelle tout de même
pour les ménages aisés d'abord ceux qui
paient l'impôt sur la fortune isf sera
alourdie notamment pour les 800
patrimoine supérieur à 100 millions de
francs
quant à l'assurance vie l'exonération de
droits de succession sera relié au delà
d'un million de francs enfin les
automobilistes qui possèdent une voiture
diesel verront la taxe sur le gazole
augmenté de 7 centimes pour se
rapprocher de l'essence sans plomb qui
elle n'augmentera pas l'an prochain
c'est promis dans le détail donc
maintenant un point qui n'est pas
négligeable pour les automobilistes la
disparition progressive de la différence
de taxation du gazole par rapport à
l'essence c'est une satisfaction donner
aux écologistes
benoît mousse et jacques gérard 7
centimes de plus par litre et par an
pendant sept ans comme on pouvait s'y
attendre c'est vraiment la grogne chez
des consommateurs du gasoil comme
d'habitude font pénaliser les gens qui
travaillent des gens
la richesse jeu rarement par un père et
ses non augmentation de gasoil passer un
petit scandale parce qu'on fait ce
tirage cela va être plus cher ils vont
payer gazelles ou plus cher suivra le
titre parce que ça les constructeurs
entre exige des soins
j'aime bien changer le dulce lamentable
du côté des constructeurs justement la
nouvelle a été mal accueillie surtout
qu'en 15 ans les ventes de voitures des
landes énormément progressé c'est un
ennui pour les utilisateurs car les
utilisateurs de moteurs diesel sont des
gens qui travaillent avec leurs
véhicules qui font beaucoup de
kilométrage et pour eux naturellement sa
vie assure surcroît de de taxer de donc
ça va handicaper leur budget les
transporteurs routiers eux s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux
le gouvernement va créer un carburant
professionnel moins cher que le gasoil
grand public une mesure attendue qui
ravit les intérêts si le gouvernement a
pris en compte tous nos arguments de
matière économique et manière
environnementale c'est une victoire pour
nous parce que enfin au moment
précisément où nous ouvrons les
frontières nous avons nous disposons des
mêmes conditions de concurrence que les
joueurs voulaient professionnels de
l'industrie pétrolière cette maison sur
les gasol est insuffisante
ils réclament toujours une réduction des
taxes sur l'essence sans plomb
autre réforme qui touche à la 25
millions de français pas moins la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation étalé
sur cinq ans à partir de l'an 2000 avec
une baisse pour certains et une hausse
plafonnée à 15% pour d'autres les
modalités de cette taxe n'avait pas été
revu depuis 1971 dominique barrouche
pascal quint il ya au moins un jour où
catherine gervais aimerait faire entrer
le fisc chez elle c'est quand elle paye
sa taxe d'habitation car elle veut des
explications pourquoi on déménage on à
l'intérieur d'evry à surface et confort
égal
cet impôt a augmenté de 20% pour un
quartier pourtant moins coté que je
trouve qu'il n'est pas logique c'est que
pour le lam là même la même chose y ait
des gens qui payent plus cher et
d'autres moins cher genevois ccsa kim
qui m'interpelle c'est précisément ce
que veut corriger le ministre de
l'économie
la taxe d'habitation est calculée sur la
valeur locative sorte de loyer fictif
établi par les services fiscaux en 1970
en quarante ans des zones rurales sont
devenus des villes tandis que d'anciens
quartiers insalubres sont réhabilités en
clair des zones pauvres sont devenus
riches et vice versa sans que la taxe ne
change
qui est grave c'est qu'on est incapable
de pouvoir expliquer simplement pourquoi
un tel pays telle somme de taxe
d'habitation
c'est devenu un maquis dans lequel on ne
peut pas expliquer aux citoyens
qu'est ce qu'ils payent à quoi ça sert
la réforme propose donc aujourd'hui de
réactualiser la base de calcul de la
taxe d'habitation en tenant compte de
l'évolution de l'immobilier
ainsi le montant de l'impôt devrait
baisser dans les zones hlm et augmenter
dans les quartiers rénovés
tous n'y gagneront pas cela explique
pourquoi cette révision prête depuis six
ans déjà
n'a encore jamais été appliquée au
chapitre des réactions qui ont suivi ces
annonces de ce matin d'abord le
président de la république qui par
avance à l'occasion de son intervention
télévisée du 14 juillet avait répété
qu'il fallait donner la priorité à la
réduction de la pression fiscale et à la
diminution des dépenses publiques
considérant que celle ci restait trop
forte en france wire perd aujourd'hui on
parle d'un budget des illusions et les
communistes qui n'ont pas obtenu
satisfaction sur plusieurs points
notamment l'impôt sur la fortune préfère
se féliciter des baisses de tva annoncée
michaël darmon et pierre lang constants
nous attendons du gouvernement qu'il
réduise la dépense publique qu'il a
augmenté attendons du gouvernement qu'il
réduise les prélèvements obligatoires
les impôts il le fait de façon infime
nous attendions également de l'état qui
réduise le déficit il le fait mais très
modestement en amorçant aujourd'hui la
réforme la taxe professionnelle le
gouvernement va certainement dans le
sens souhaité par les entreprises il le
fait petitement mais il le fait tout de
même pour alléger les charges sur
l'emploi et nous avons toujours dit et
le gouvernement semble le reconnaître qu
alléger les charges sur l'emploi c'est
favoriser l'emploi n'a pas de réformes
de structure qui est engagée à
l'occasion de cette relance de l'a27 du
soutien de cette croissance qui est
beaucoup plus importante que prévu il
aurait fallu en profiter pour baisser
les dépenses et à ce moment là on aurait
pu vraiment baisser les impôts ce qui
est une vraie politique libérale on
n'est pas du tout dans une politique
libérale
on est dans un esprit de trucs social
démocrate avec quelques cadeaux
communiste oui c'est un budget électoral
où on veut faire plaisir à tout le monde
mais il n'y a aucune mesure de fond
aucune mesure en profondeur par exemple
les mesures qui ont pour but de lutter
contre le chômage d'allègement des
charges sur les bas salaires que 2 puis
bérégovoy balladur juppé
tout le monde a poursuivi cet effort y
avec succès puisque le chômage baisse et
le gouvernement jospin y renonce
a priori donc un budget 99 facilitée par
la reprise économique mais qui ne règle
pas forcément tous les problèmes de fond
ont écouté pouvoir à la fois augmenter
les dépenses budgétaires réduire les
déficits et dispenser quelques cadeaux
fiscaux de c'est le miracle de la
croissance
magic strauss kahn comme le surnomment
déjà l'utilisent pour trois objectifs
premièrement l'emploi avec la
suppression de la part salariale de la
taxe professionnelle un allègement pour
les entreprises de 30 milliards de cet
impôt autrefois qualifié d'imbécile
allègements qui semblent donner raison
aux thèses des libéraux et du patronat
sur les méfaits des charges sociales et
fiscales
en tout cas du baume au coeur pour les
entreprises après les 35 heures
deuxièmement la justice sociale histoire
de rappeler que le gouvernement est de
gauche et de rasséréner la majorité
plurielle les plus riches seront ils
seront un peu de leur poche avec un
alourdissement de l'impôt sur la fortune
les ménages profiteront de quelques
baisses de tva des frais de notaire si
tu achète un logement et de la
disparition de quelques taxes archaïque
enfin troisièmement l'objectif c'est
celui de la mort ça pas compter d'une
réforme fiscale sur la taxe d'habitation
dont on actualise on l'a vu les bases de
calcul et sur le gazole qui mettra tout
de même sept ans à combler son retard
sur l'essence au total les réductions
d'impôts avoisine les 16 milliards c'est
bien trop peu pour l'opposition qui y
voit un gaspillage de la croissance ce
que confirme l'elysée en termes plus
galants dominique strauss kahn lui parie
sur un soutien de cette croissance qu'il
escompte solide et durable l'avenir les
départagera dans l' affaire de dopage de
l'équipe festina on attend pour demain
une convocation des coureurs par la
justice dans le milieu les langues
continuent de se délier après les
professionnels on apprend que dans la
région de poitiers notamment des
coureurs amateurs se sont vu proposer un
cocktail dopants d'étonnant mais très
dangereux
dans le jargon des cyclistes il est
surnommé le pot belge françois privat
philippe rix pour rompre le silence cet
homme coureur cycliste amateur a choisi
de garder l'anonymat
actuellement il participe à des courses
de niveau national dans l'antichambre du
professionnalisme
récemment un autre coureur lui a proposé
de lui procurer des doses de pot belge
un cocktail dopants particulièrement
dangereux à base de stupéfiants à
l'origine fabriquée en belgique alors la
première fois c'était sur une course à
laquelle j'ai abandonné et je me suis
retrouvé avec un coureur qui m'a donc
parler de du pot et ensuite il m'a
expliqué est ce que c'était vraiment le
pot belge donc en détaillant ce qu'il y
avait dedans et en me disant que sur moi
ça fait ça marche très très bien et il
m'en a pas proposé tout de suite mais
j'ai compris que de toute façon je pour
en avoir par son intermédiaire ou que
c'était fassiez en tout cas d'en avoir
mois de juin dernier un toxicologue a
procédé à l'analyse de ce produit
qu'auparavant ne trouvait pas dans les
pelotons amateurs un mélange
d'amphétamine de caféine d'antalgiques
et surtout de cocaïne et d'héroïne
jusqu'à présent le dopage sportif
concerné utiliser exclusivement des
médicaments on s'aperçoit que plus ça va
et plus on utilise maintenant des
stupéfiants
et là ça devient dramatique quand on a
su ce qu'il y avait dedans
on a porté plainte puisqu'il fallait
qu'on sache un petit peu qu'on détruise
le mal à la racine et qu'on sache un
petit peu s'il y avait des réseaux
organisés parce que en tant que médecin
on a peur que des cyclistes moeurs une
enquête judiciaire est en cours mais
depuis 1995 chez les amateurs c'est
surtout de paix ou que l'on parle comme
chez les pros
même si un traitement coûte au moins
8000 fois très difficile pas difficile
d'y arriver
j'irai en étant à l'eau minérale ça
devient de plus en plus ça roule très
très vite et bombay même si le p o mais
l'avis des coureurs en danger la limite
c'est un risque qui prend
personnellement et on y pense plus à dix
on a l'argent qu'il pourra gagner chez
les professionnels plus qu'à sa santé
les cyclistes amateurs pris entre deux
feux d'un côté un désir de performance
et d'argent de l'autre un suivi médical
diane inférieur à celui des
professionnels
quant à la deuxième étape de montagne
dans les pyrénées aujourd'hui le tour de
france elle a vu la victoire du grimpeur
italien pantani comme chaque année ou
presque
l'allemand ulrich conserve son maillot
jaune plan gautreau alain poiré un
formidable soleil et sans doute une peur
terrible pour le suisse mayer qui chute
dans la descente du col de la core
voilà comment s'écrit une épopée car
meyer va repartir
il va même mené la course seul jusqu'à 8
km de l'arrivée mais la dernière
ascension vers bay et lui sera fatale à
cause d'un coureur
marco pantani les screens heures d'école
est parti personne ne le reverra
derrière oulrich se fait peur l'allemand
qui a crevé s'offre un slalom prêt
spécial pour revenir en tête du peloton
sans équipier il accélère la cadence
pour limiter l'écart avec pantani
ullrich défend son maillot jaune
tellement bien qu'ils lâchent jalabert
le champion de france va perdre
finalement 23 secondes dans la bataille
il a su faire mais il n'a pas craqué
je suis capable de maintenir une bonne
cadence et de continuer à monter fort et
de limiter les dégâts bon c'est sûr
c'est pas comme ça qu'on gagne le tour
mais bon c'est pas non plus la bienvenue
le grimpeur du jour c'est pantani qui
n'est ficelé virage pyrénéen aussi bien
que les lacets de l'alpe d'huez à une
minute trente
dans le sillage d'une riche l'américain
jay leach est aidé par le surprenant
français christophe rinero mais
aujourd'hui personne ne pouvait battre
le dernier vainqueur du tour d'italie
qui revient à 3 minutes bull riesch au
classement général
la gloire pour pantani les honneurs au
meilleur deuxième
malgré sa chute spectaculaire les deux
étapes pyrénéennes ont rendu le verdict
peu qu'on attendait pantani est plus que
jamais le meilleur grimpeur du monde et
ulrich est toujours le plus fort du
peloton
jalabert et les autres outsiders eux ont
laissé des forces et des minutes pour la
montagne
pour eux la journée de repos arrive au
bon moment l'industriel de la lunette
alain afflelou placé quelques heures en
garde à vue aujourd'hui à paris dans le
cadre d'une enquête sur des montages
financiers suspects du temps où il était
président du club de football des
girondins de bordeaux dans le courant de
l'après midi alain flow est ressorti
libre du palais de justice de paris adp
rend simplement qu'il avait fourni
toutes les indications utiles aux
enquêteurs et qui n'avait rien à se
reprocher en corse l'ancien président de
la caisse régionale du crédit agricole
françois musso interpellé hier a été mis
en examen et écroué aujourd'hui ajaccio
motifs détournement de fonds publics
agnès vahramian diego garcia françois
musso aux portes de la prison où il
passera sa première nuit ce matin devant
le juge après 48 heures de garde à vue
l'ancien directeur du crédit agricole a
été mis en examen
motif recel de détournement de fonds
publics abus de confiance et de biens
sociaux des charges lourdes pour la
première personnalité politique
d'importance de lille à être écroué
françois musso est en effet un ancien
député européen rpr ancien chargé de
mission à la ville de paris
tous les chefs de mise en examen son
camp que free absolument plus
comment est-ce qu'il a réagi justement
la mise en détention de la façon la plus
sereine et la plus digne c'est conforme
d'ailleurs à son personnage la justice
reproche à françois musso d'avoir
bénéficié de prêts abusifs de la part de
la banque qu'il dirige est 10 millions
de francs de crédits au titre de
l'agriculture alors que selon un rapport
de l'inspection générale des finances
françois musso n'était plus exploitants
questionné en juin dernier sur cette
affaire il n'avait d'ailleurs pas venu
s'expliquer je dis bien je ne dirais pas
françois musso a fait appel de sa mise
en détention
la justice elle continue d'enquêter sur
ce qu'elle pense être un système
généralisé de détournement de fonds et
puis un nouvel attentat ce matin contre
la voiture d'un policier de bastia qui a
explosé il n'y a pas eu de blessé c'est
le quatrième attentat en trois jours
contre des intérêts policiers encore 27
mille hectares de bois et de culture
détruits c'est le bilan presque
définitif désormais de l' incendie qui a
ravagé le nord-est de la catalogne près
de barcelone pendant quatre jours la
mobilisation générale et la météo plus
clémente avec un vent qui s'est presque
entièrement calmé ont permis de
maîtriser l'incendié
dans les premières heures de la matinée
de ce mercredi vincent guyenne josé
boulesteix voilà à quoi ressemble une
partie de la catalogue aujourd'hui
quatre jours d' incendies et 27 mille
hectares de verdure ont laissé place à
la noirceur d'une forêt calcinée
maintenant que les flammes ne se sont
tus l'heure est au bilan et aux
réparations
beaucoup de ce câble la contient 200
lignes est en ce moment à tous les
villages du coin sans le téléphone c'est
le moindre soucis de ceux qui ont tout
perdu
isolé sur la colline scène ferme à
brûler avant-hier tous les yeux des
pompiers non
on n'a pas pu venir parce que nous
étions l'autre a vu le feu arrivés sur
la maison le temps qu'on arrive c'était
trop tard le paysan n'était pas là la
majorité de son troupeau a survécu mais
une douzaine de moutons sont restés
prisonniers de la bergerie rien il ne
reste rien se lamente luis il habite l
affaire il n'a pas pu sauver grand chose
on ne peut plus vivre ici maintenant
c'est trop dangereux
les pompes qui sont avec lui pour
inspecter les ruines
il ne leur en veux pas lui aurait été
impossible d'arrêter assez vite
il y avait tellement de foyers ne
pouvait pas y avoir un camion de pompier
par maison on a limité
ses limites d'autres commencent à les
critiquer sérieusement certes on est
venu à bout de cet incendie
mais à quel prix pourquoi les pompiers
était-il déborder la prévention est elle
suffisante
quelle est l'origine des feux à toutes
ces questions les autorités locales
répondront plus tard aujourd'hui encore
l'essentiel était de surveiller la forêt
pour que ne s'étendent pas plus ce
paysage de désolation après le
raz-de-marée qui a ravagé la côte de la
papouasie nouvelle guinée ce que
craignent principalement aujourd'hui les
sauveteurs et des autorités ce sont les
risques d'épidémie les dernier bilan en
date font état de 1600 morts
officiellement recensés mais toujours
plus de cinq mille disparus france mais
qui à celui là a eu de la chance
beaucoup de chance il est l'un des rares
rescapés de ce que la papouasie appelle
déjà la génération perdue car la grande
majorité des victimes sont d'abord des
enfants trop faible pour lutter contre
les murs d'eau qui les ont emportés 3000
personnes sont officiellement portées
disparues dans la région du lagon de 6 à
nos 1600 cadavres ont été retrouvés
la plus grande partie de ma famille est
morte
mon frère est mort au bassin son mari
sont morts avec leurs trois
petits-enfants tous les canaux et ont
été détruits les maisons ont été
emportées où tout est détruit
les survivants ne peuvent même pas
veillé leur mort comme l'exigé la
coutume car les cadavres sont
immédiatement incinérés pour éviter les
épidémies les secours pensent qu'une
partie des disparus terrifiés se cachent
encore dans la forêt alors il cherche
afin que les blessés ne succombe pas aux
infections afin que ceux qui ont passé
des heures dans l'eau ne sera pas décimé
par la pneumonie
mais les centres médicaux de la région
sont débordés et les médicaments
manquent déjà
l'institut national de la statistique
nous livre aujourd'hui une étude sur la
composition des familles en france leur
nombre entre les parents grands parents
frères soeurs neveux varie selon les
couches sociales la moyenne étant de 24
personnes par famille une étude qui nous
permet également d'évoquer l'évolution
de la composition de ces familles en
guérit la patrick desmure nous avons
toujours été habitué à être très
nombreux et
soutenir moralement par des coups de fil
par peinture je ne me verrais pas du
tout du tout est tout seul une maison
vide c'est pas pour vous ah non bâti sa
famille c'est une tribu quatre enfants
un mari trois soeurs des neveux et
nièces ici ou vu les joies et les peines
en famille ou avec toute la famille
comme d'ailleurs la plupart des français
l' enquête de l'insee révèle ainsi que
chacun d'entre nous dispose d'un
environnement familial composé de vingt
personnes s'il en est cadre 27 personnes
si l'on est ouvrier la famille moyenne
pour chaque français est de 24 personnes
beaucoup est-ce que c'est moins qu'avant
est-ce que c'est plus 40 que je crois
que c'est différent
du passé dans la mesure où ou sait lire
et ses relations familiales dans cercle
élargi comporte de nouveaux types de
relation les demi-frères les demi-soeurs
les beaux parents
des grands parents aussi que l'on que
l'on connaît compte tenu de
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie de
plus en plus longtemps voire des
arrière-grands-parents dire que les
générations quand même cohabitent de
plus en plus longtemps dans le temps
dans la dans la vie des individus les
individus qui vivent encore aujourd'hui
la famille comme un refuge face aux
difficultés économiques jours à propos
des de la famille et plus exactement de
la mémoire familiale à marseille
une initiative déjà couronnée de succès
dans le monde anonyme qui est le lot de
beaucoup actuellement un homme a eu
l'idée de faire enregistrer à tous ceux
qui veulent laisser un témoignage de
leur vie 1 cd qu'ils peuvent ensuite
distribués à leurs enfants à leurs
familles la formule fonctionne et l'on
s'aperçoit cette occasion que beaucoup
de vies ne sont pas sans intérêt
yannick à rossi jean françois brun tout
commence comme la visite du médecin de
famille mais c'est un docteur d'un genre
un peu particulier qui travaille sur la
mémoire pas d'amnésie
mais plutôt l'héritage la vie d'une
famille dans son magnétophone des heures
de souvenirs d'anecdotes savait pas
voilées
cette famille d'origine sicilienne
établies en tunisie puis en mars elle a
été séduite par le projet de
l'association auboise édité en disque
compact l'histoire d'une vie et là c'est
comme si nous entendre même quatre
heures d'enregistrements cours 2h15 de
produits finis montage musique un
traitement radiophonique pouvoir
remplacer tout la veillée au coin du feu
tout ce qui se faisait avant tout
l'héritage oral qui est qu'on ne fait
plus maintenant on connaît souvent de
plus la vie de personnes connues que
celles de sa propre famille voilà d'où
est née l'idée un coffret pour chaque
membre de la famille le disque compact
est un support inusable et facile
d'utilisation pour le plaisir d'écouter
à l'infini bien installé dans un
fauteuil l'héritage familial
lorsqu'on parle pollution c'est le plus
souvent pour évoquer les fumées
industrielles et celles des automobiles
mais la pollution sonore est également
un fléau
la ville de strasbourg vient de se doter
d'une réglementation en tri bruit très
strictes et qui ne concerne pas
seulement le tapage nocturne mais aussi
les bricoleurs de l'homme et les
jardiniers du soir christine beauce
patrice schoumaker il y avait 10 ans
l'ordre incontestable
il est nécessaire comme ces chantiers
publics ou privés et puis il ya deux ans
plus heureux d'y un concert d'aboiements
ou réveil en fanfare au son de la
tondeuse à gazon du voisin effets
ravageurs garantie tous ces bruits
gênants font à présent l'objet d'une
reine
la stricte codification your hair
climatiseurs et autoradios n'y échappe
pas d'abord le souci de préserver la
santé des strasbourgeois
d'autre part de faire cohabiter une
ville touristique une ville jeune avec
des personnes qui veulent dormir et
travaillant pour cela strasbourg s'est
dotée depuis deux ans d'une brigade
environnement 14 policiers municipaux
qui sillonnent les quartiers à vélo 20
heures sur 24 principales missions les
problèmes du voisinage qu'il tente de
régler à l'amiable mais également des
plaintes concernant les bars et boîtes
de nuit et là les amendes sont peu
dissuasif sur 1500 francs ça dépend
d'eux
de la répétition mais donc ce qui est le
moyen le plus efficace de faire cesser
donc voir dans des cas comme ça donc
c'est une fermeture administrative qui
est quand même pendant un mois et une
nouveauté la ville peut exiger une étude
acoustique avant d'accorder une
autorisation d'ouverture à un
établissement
les patrons de bars n'ont pas attendu
cet arrêté pour prendre des dispositions
au cas lors de face autorisé tout le
monde a fait les efforts là dessus une
appli problème quoi racheter terra santé
le plus grand possible
nous avons des containers à bouteilles
ont dit ce matin le soir je suis trop
justement ne pas déranger et si cela ne
suffit pas il reste la campagne avec ses
bruits familiers
l'actualité internationale jusqu'à ce
jour
les algériens avaient toujours refusé
l'idée d'une ingérence étrangère
étrangères pardon dans la guerre civile
qui ne porte pas son nom là bas il faut
bien remarquer qu'aujourd'hui pour la
première fois même si elle est très
encadré une mission des nations unies
vient d'arriver à alger l'un de ses
membres n'est autre que madame simone
girard griesbeck jean françois renaud
reportage c'est avec trois heures de
retard sur l'horaire prévu que la
délégation des nations unies est arrivé
à alger le sourire et l'amabilité était
de rigueur mais le mutisme était
d'oreilles aucune déclaration du côté
algérien
même chose du côté de la délégation
étrange politique qui consiste à ne pas
communiquer le programme de la visite
n'a toujours pas été rendu public
difficile pour la presse étrangère de
pouvoir travailler alors on est allé
voir nos confrères des journaux
algériens pour qui les choses sont
encore plus compliquées
ils risquent leur vie pour nous informer
et d'abord le dernier né de la presse
écrite
la nouvelle république ils n'ont pas
plus de 35 ans ils veulent visiblement
que les choses changent
le titre nouvelle république en est le
symbole çà et là il faut pas aussi et 3
p 1,3 à gérer à dire que peut-être
l'événement de cette mission marque n'a
pas été n'est pas aussi important donc
événement que ce qui s'est passé
récemment par exemple en kabylie a
aujourd'hui pas de pressions extérieures
puisque pour le moment la visite de la
mission des nations unies se résume à un
grand silence
il faut bien reconnaître que c'est dans
la plus grande discrétion que la chine
vient de lancer un satellite français
baptisé longue marche qui rappelle
l'épopée héroïque de mauro cetto
ce lancement a eu lieu en coopération
techniciens chinois et français au sein
d'une même équipe dans des conditions il
faut le dire beaucoup plus ristic que
celle de cours ou encore de cap
canaveral aux états unis ce qui n'a pas
empêché le lancement d'être un succès et
exceptionnellement et bien les autorités
chinoises nous ont permis de filmer ce
départ isabelle bechler est tristan le
moins à chaque tir les curieux viennent
se poster sur cette colline à 5 km à vol
d'oiseau d'une des trois bases spatiales
top secret de chine
attrait un échec meurtrier voilà deux
ans et demi c'était le quatrième
lancement réussi de la fusée longue
marche 3b à son bord un satellite
français j'ai fait quatre jours de route
pour venir voir le lancement très ému ça
veut dire que la chine est maintenant
parmi les pays acp et plus développé du
match aller à bannu prix toujours pour
que ça réussisse pas vrai je les veux
exploser une fois qu'est ce que ça t'a
fait orban vous savez j'étais très
triste
nous sommes à 1850 mètres d'altitude au
saut de schwann en zone de minorité nick
fry base militaire de six chang c'est
ici que la chine veut concurrencer cours
ou baïkonour et autre cap canaveral des
ingénieurs d'aérospatiale kahn met la
dernière main à un satellite français
dans le plus grand secret de ce bâtiment
les militaires chinois doivent montrer
patte blanche c'est un bâtiment réservé
aux français
là on se passionne c'est confidentiel
défense manquant nous compterons comme
les accès au paquet de problèmes dans le
secret d'une salle dépoussiérer c'est un
véritable patchwork de feuilles de métal
réflecteurs qui doit protéger les
équipements du rayonnement solaire et
des poussières cosmiques de la haute
couture technologique
c'est un opérateur chinois qui a
commandé le satellite voilà deux ans
sinosat servira pour la téléphonie la
télédiffusion
mais surtout pour les communications de
données bancaires sont en train
actuellement de mettre au point un
système qui va peut-être leur permettre
d'éviter de passer par l'intermédiaire
du chéquier et d'aller directement de
l'argent liquide à l'argent monotype
pour cela il faut un système fiable sûre
rapide de transfert de données
ce symphonie pour bien servir entre
autres à cette mission et les
techniciens français et allemands qui
travaillent sur le site ne prenne pas de
liberté avec les lampes de sécurité
surtout quand il risque le contact avec
les carburants hautement toxiques
côté chinois nous verrons bientôt que
les normes sont quasi inexistantes 30 à
60 techniciens et ingénieurs français
exilé dans un fonds de vallées ce choix
n'est cependant plus d'un mois et demi
cela requiert une certaine logistique
pendant les bons produits fruits entre
eux mêmes du chou fleur chou à la
bretagne n'est pas loin ce soir du feu
de hors-d'oeuvre blanquette de veau à
l'ancienne avec pilar par breton et il
faut veiller au plus près au moral des
troupes car le travail est minutieux
rien ne peut être laissé au hasard et
personne ne peut se permettre de tomber
malade
une fois ajoutés les derniers carburant
la tour de service pas quitter la fusée
longue marche
le décompte final est lancé la fusée est
une véritable bombe
cela n'empêche pas les chinois de faire
visiter la base à leurs hôtes de marque
et de prendre des photos souvenirs
l'ensemble la station paraît simple
d'ailleurs d'une façon générale
les relations avec nos amis chinois
montrent qu'ils ont une approche
pragmatique et que je trouve
je ne dirais pas simpliste mais j'ai dit
simple donc scène probablement des
opérations la salle de contrôle
militaire n'est accessible qu'à trois
étrangers les allemands qui ont
cofinancé le satellite et le chef de
mission français il examine le pas de
tir à distance
ici des hommes marchent au pied de la
fusée sans protection apparente là
l'ingénieur allemand a distingué
quelques flammes pas très normal
une information bien par ses airs on
apprend beaucoup eu deux côtés il faut
être philosophe patients et surtout
kaunas traduisez qu'il faut des nerfs
d'acier pour faire avec la bureaucratie
le sens du secret l'obsession du
contrôle des chinois
mais on finit par oublier ses
vicissitudes quand le lanceur s'élève à
une poussée de plus de 5 tonnes et place
finalement correctement le satellite en
orbite
la mort à l'âge de 74 ans de l'ancien
astronaute américain alan shepard en
1961 souvenez vous il avait été le
premier américain à effectuer un séjour
dans l'espace très court il avait été
devancé de quelques semaines par le
russe youri gagarine
le cinéma ne fait pas relâche on était
sortie aujourd'hui du numéro 4 de larmes
fatale les exploits de l'agent martin
riggs alias mel gibson vedette du
premier numéro il ya onze ans la star
américaine a finalement accepté de
reprendre le rôle est de répondre aussi
à nos questions pascal deschamps je suis
trop vieux pour ces conneries mais aussi
il l'avait dit après le numéro 3 plus
jamais après avoir résisté près de sept
ans le lieutenant riggs reprend du
service
on a fini par lui offrir un chèque
conséquent mais surtout dit-il
un bon script cocktail réussi d'action
et d'humour qui avait fait le succès des
précédents
tous les ans il faisait en quelque sorte
le siège allez on en fait un aussi court
on savait pour les studios il y a un
gros enjeu commercial dans tous ses
suites
je le comprends je comprends tout à fait
les règles du commerce au business
c'est pour ça que je suis là à faire
mais mes sept ans pour moi c'était le
bon moment
les producteurs ont soigné le retour du
héros un budget encore plus important
pour des casquettes plus spectaculaire
un scénario bien ficelé qui mêle triades
chinoises et trafic d'esclaves des
dialogues taillé sur mesure mais martin
reese a été contraint d'évoluer à 40 ans
passés il songe à fonder une famille
rien à voir donc avec le flic aux
tendances suicidaires qui lui avait valu
son surnom d' arme fatale
ce que j'aimais chez ce type au début
c'est qu'il n'était pas dans la
normalité
alors bien sûr aujourd'hui il est un peu
rentré dans le rang mais ça correspond
tout autant à quelque chose de bien
réelles
bien que les situations soient
totalement excentré aux états unis
l'armé fatale 4 caracole en tête du box
office estival et s'y colle pour chacune
des superproductions les critiques
américains font la fine bouche mais elle
n'en a cure
les critiques ça me laisse aide
quelqu'un m'a demandé un jour mais que
répondez vous aux critiques qui vous ont
critiqué il n'ya qu'une seule chose à
leur répondre
je suis riche oscar du meilleur
réalisateur avec brève et mel gibson dit
plutôt bien la double casquette à se
consacre désormais un autre projet une
nouvelle adaptation de fahrenheit 451 33
ans après truchot suite des défilés de
la haute couture de l'hiver prochain
aujourd'hui place aux maîtres
incontestés yves saint laurent qui fête
cette année ses 40 ans de création une
présentation qui a impressionné par sa
sobriété qui prouve une maîtrise
complète de son art sophie mais elle
bernard claude catto encore à prouver
quand on s'appelle yves saint laurent
que l'une est vénérée depuis 40 ans
comment ils nous voir après tant
d'années comment surprendre dans ce
milieu où la poudre aux yeux et si
souvent plus aguicheuse que l' extrême
pureté îles saint laurent a aujourd'hui
repris un à un tous les maux de son
vocabulaire personnel 1 1 il a égrainé
le smoking labousse transparente
la petite robe noire l'essence même de
son style s'affirme et déjà dans ce
défilé
mais l'on jeune homme timide s'était
fait un nom succédant à dior il
s'exposait ici pour la deuxième fois
sous sa propre edmonde charles-roux à
l'époque rédactrice en chef du magazine
gogh était déjà une fidèle à son style à
lui et est qu'à lui et qui n'a jamais
cessé de l'épuré et c'est une c'est une
recherche tellement rare
vous voyez plutôt des couturiers qui
rajoute
il s'inspire il prend des idées mais il
en fait des idées salants
dans la salle pour la première fois
invités jean paul gaultier un troublions
un exubérant pense-t-on qui a pourtant
toujours désigné yves saint laurent
comme sondes
depuis des années il rêvait d'être la
rencontre de deux générations de deux
couturiers d'exception mais très émue et
et vraiment je ne sais pas s'il a
ressenti mais la réelle émotion que
j'avais en le croyant
voilà je suis vraiment c'est vrai depuis
que je suis gamin j'ai vu c'est
cependant qui m'ont fait rêver tous là
je vois en vrai une collection entière
bon bah pour moi c'est un moment
important
j'ai l'impression quand même qu'avec
cette collection et sa quarantième
anniversaire c'était un peu d'artifices
extraordinaire comme j'ai rarement vu
autant de rondes histoire aussi sublime
dans une collection pas de besoin de
nuit pratiquement pas de couleurs
simplement l'essentiel comme un trait de
crayon
cette collection ressembler à une ultime
révérence
l'aboutissement d'une carrière
pourquoi
son collection créée par l'adie ma vie
chez les roms on murmure que il met le
saint-laurent pouvait se mutiner
sera-t-il vivre sans la couture et
surtout sa couture sera t-elle vivre
sans lui on nous quitter le rappel du
principal titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi le budget 99 marquée par un
allègement de la taxe professionnelle
favorable d'entreprise refonte de la
taxe d'habitation pour les particuliers
le début d'une réforme fiscale engagée
par le gouvernement contesté par
l'opposition
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinez avec un temps plutôt calme et
plutôt bourg pour demain ça c'est pour
les vacances il je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir à demain